hey guys welcome back to your weekly
dead stream recap and we have a ton of
news to cover today so be sure to stay
to the end and listen to everything I
have to say a lot of stuff toward the
end is very important so please stick
toward the end of the video but anybody
guys let's get right into this stuff so
the first thing on the list is now
players can now adjust their dead zone
on controllers for PC and console users
if you don't know what dead zone is
basically you can modify the dead zone
so that you only have to press the right
trigger or RT or R - I believe on ps4
just a little bit for it to make the
game to register that you are swinging
instead of smashing it all the way down
it's for a kind of like a faster
reaction time and button mapping is also
being worked on for council and
basically button mapping for council for
console players we always have to rely
on presets that the game gave us if you
didn't like the preset or if you'd like
to half of it and not the other half you
had to deal with it shut the [ __ ] up but
now they're making it to that but
mapping is a thinks of which we can now
customize our own presets make it so
that we can have whatever we want we can
have the guard break on the right d-pad
or anything else that we choose to have
this is a lot just a big step for us
console players Plus this also works for
PC players using a controller the next
couple things we have are about gear set
gear stats are going to have a different
curve for obtaining gear so it's a lot
easier to catch up with new characters
and also speaking of new characters
characters went little to no gear as
like a starting character such as the
new two new characters coming out you'll
have an easier time finding people with
max level stats they had they did not
say what but they will give them a
benefit also with gear there is a new
rarity of gear called
orange and it will be obtainable in
packs at rep 5 or higher this is
supposed to raise the gear score limit I
don't exactly know the number but it is
definitely raised the gear stats that
are also actually been removed from the
game our feet cooldown reduction block
damage resistance throw distance and
sprint speed that all of them are being
removed from the game and the new gear
stead that's being added is defensive
penetration which hopefully should from
the sounds of it help against turtling
enemies now the question is what if you
have one of the gear stats like I have I
have
max almost I have a pretty high level
Kenzie I'm rep 6 and I have max sprint
speed so what gets replaced with sprint
speed a lot of people are assuming this
damage penetration is going to be split
off and it's in three different
categories like in the feed cooldown
reduction and the block damage
resistance and the sprint speed wherever
those happen to line your weapon or
armor are going to be replaced with
damage penetration you probably have the
same number so instead of me having max
sprint speed I'll have max damage
penetration if that's what most of us
unvetted are kind of assuming now these
aren't out just yet as I'm saying this
but they hopefully will be added by the
end by the start of season 2 on top of
that for new weapons and two new armors
are being added to every character they
did not exactly specify what the type of
combo with their staffers but or what
they look like what each character is
getting something each character also
got two or also got a new mythic outfit
that does cost fifteen thousand each
comes with their own unique ornament and
effect the Knights effect is a Firefly
the Vikings have bats surrounding them
and the samurai have butterflies which I
will play for you right now and I will
see you when that's over
you
please
[Music]
see guys I thought those are pretty cool
my personal favorites as you saw on the
thumb note we're lawyering or concur and
Kent same evening at Kent's a Maine I'm
not too sure I liked some of the Viking
outfits I do like their aura their
effect but the ornament and the outfits
weren't - weren't too flashy for me
anyway let's continue on the next thing
that's being addressed is that XP gain
is now increased by 25% permanently
making it easier to rank up new
characters so they're stuck at a low
level being destroyed by high level
characters of max stats now with this
whole new gear stat revamp I don't even
know if that even matters anymore also
at the beginning of season 2 whether
you're a season pass owner or not you
will get 12 days of free champion status
and for scavenger crates so feel free to
use those when you rank up the centering
and shinobi or a new character besides
those two two new maps are being
released temple garden and forge I do
not have any pictures I don't believe
there was any pictures showing during
the dev stream but as soon as those come
out I will gladly show some pictures of
what they are on top of that Centurion
and shinobi also got full trailer
reveals they're about a minute and a
half along the two minutes for each of
the characters I would have put it in
the end of this video but I would rather
not get copyrighted like Yuki's updated
in the last time when I talked about
outfits so I'll just leave them down in
the description for your own pleasure so
feel free to check that out and lastly
Ubisoft is having a livestream showing
off the new characters and kind of
gameplay a day before they get released
on May 15 at 2 p.m. Pacific Time or PPD
I don't exactly know what anybody else's
time zone is I know mine which is
Eastern Time so anybody in the East
Coast that'll be around 5 p.m.
anywhere else I'm sorry I just don't
live in those area so I wouldn't notice
you have to figure it out yourself I
know my guys I hope you did enjoy this
fantastic video I did I kind of liked
some of these changes tell me in the
comments below what you think of the new
mythic outfits your personal favorite
and anything else that has to do with
the new gear stats what you did and
didn't like about this dev stream we
tell me in the comments I'd love to know
and I'd love to start a discussion with
you anyway guys I will see you all in
the next video and peace upwards have a
great rest of your day